[Music]
unfortunately has not been deleted the
fact that he's mr stumps from probably a
yard away
that's just not a very good bit of
cricket really is it
hi i'm ben stokes and this is rate my
skills sports bible i'm going to pick my
three favorite clips and the winners
will receive some adidas merchandise
not sure about this technique here
that's a no balls bounced three times
what
no way that's settled that's that's not
real cricket one bounce two bouncer no
ball right
still can be run out for no ball which
they do a good job of fantastic
they're blaming each other in a run out
it does everyone's happy
he's not happy he's through his back
he's held on for it too long and he's
through it teammates
no
that's
wow and now they're making it up
i'm sure they'll settle with a pint in
the bar after
oh my god
i mean
the wicked keeper's got short stuff that
just sums up what type of cricket this
is
oh funny there you go
that's not the thing that i was
expecting to see after
the state is absolutely buffing it down
and firstly
quite old so i wasn't really expecting
to see him diving full length and taking
an absolute world he would whatever but
give him 10 out of 10 for that to be
honest
unfortunately has not been deleted
i mean there's no such thing as an easy
catch
although that's very close to being
called me to catch but the fact that
he's missed the stuns from probably a
yard away
that's just not a very good bit of
cricket really is it and who on the
england team is most likely to stitch
you up with a recording like that
sam billings
he thinks he's like an influencer or
something like that but we call him
influenza
that's how bad he is at doing it so
we got commentary
what's happened there
is he caught that
water catch
oh my god he has i didn't even notice
that
i'm gonna go play that again
oh my word
i don't think anyone else really i
didn't even notice it
that's awesome i mean that's either you
take he's cut he's either catching that
or he's
got
new teeth to worry about that's good
effort i think he was more he's caught
that out self-preservation mode
it's got to be a lot that's a lockdown
video again
i mean first thoughts is he's wearing a
inner thigh pad on his outer leg we
won't say that on board considering he's
managed to hit a tea bag
into a cup of coffee
that's good
i mean
this one this is probably one of the
most famous
cricketing clips
no matter how many times you see that
you're still gonna get a laugh i i think
this guy right i reckon he's that you
know he he knows exactly what he's doing
he comes across as one of those people
that whatever he does
people are going to laugh i think it
just he's one of those people you know
he's like yeah this cricket game is easy
like watch give me the kit i'll go out
and do do the business
so in third place we have the gentleman
who manages to hit a teabag this cricket
bat straight into a mug um
very hard to do but he managed to do it
so well done very impressed
in second place i mean it's one of the
you know
the all-time great cricket village
cricket videos of the man with a ice
hockey mask as a helmet who manages to
fall over and destroy his slumps with
his own back
and in first place my favorite video
clip and winner of the adidas
merchandise has got to be the absolute
screamer of a one-handed catch-up first
slip i don't know how old he is i don't
want to do many adjusters but he looks
like he's um he's on the side of
retirement so even more impressive that
he's able to to do what he did uh
at his age because i certainly wouldn't
be able to do that five years time later
on how old he is very impressive well
done that great catch
this is a oh
oh he's good
why didn't sky blue though should be in
red that's the problem that's the
biggest problem with this kid he's
wearing the wrong colour
oh he's not scored that that is
unbelievable
wow was that cross as well do you think
or do you think he's meant to chip it
into the back post
it doesn't really matter does it the bit
before it was fantastic